hunger chiefly I mean China was a hungry
place literally a starving country for
parts of the year at large parts of the
country well into the 80s conservative
estimates of the number dead of
starvation of the great leap forward in
the late 50s is 35 million I mean those
are some pretty those are some pretty
significant numbers the upper estimate
is more like 50 million take California
and throw in a few other pretty
good-sized states and you let the entire
population starve to death that's kind
of what you're looking at I guess on a
percentage basis it would more of it
like be if everyone in Florida had
starved to death but just in an enormous
numbers and people don't you know if you
haven't had protein for six weeks and a
pigeon goes by you're not thinking oh
what a pretty bird you know or even if
it's a bald eagle you're thinking
protein on wing you know so a lot of it
is purely economic and and I think
George Packer I think his his best
insight about Iraq when he went there
immediately after the invasion was that
the American planner is among all the
many things they were not taking to
account we're not taking into account
the psychological damage the decades
under Saddam had inflicted that never
mind political structure nevermind you
know are there theaters where people
could express their political views
never mind economic infrastructure if
you have an entire generation that has
gone through the miseries of that
dictatorship and has never really known
but what it's like to have political
rights and is living in us in a police
state and has you know seen every you
know everybody had a brother who died
fighting Iran and all of that stuff it
it doesn't matter what you give them
because they're so shell-shocked by the
experience of those decades and and
China's a not as extreme because it was
not kind of such a big place since
there's so much going on in it and
they're always pockets where something
there's a direct contradiction to the
last thing you just said but still
broadly speaking it wasn't like the
first half of the 20th century was so
great for them and then there was a
great leap forward and then there was a
cultural revolution and then there was
the Gang of Four period it was basically
just it was a miserable miserable place
and there's the sense of rebound which
is you know like all I want is not to be
miserable the way my parents were all
the parents want is not first for their
children and their grandchildren not to
be miserable the way they were and the
misery was so deep and so endemic and so
thorough going on so many levels that
you have the sense that people just like
don't talk to me about that right now
the watchword in the late 80s it was
actually given an official national wat
word which was development first that
environment and part of that is the
theory that you know as people have a
little more money than they can afford
to have the leisure and the means to
worry about these things but there was a
very deliberate decision made you know
stop forcing people to eat ideology and
let them have you know I phones and and
it's very hard when you actually go to
China and talk to people they're very
hard to want to deny them their iPhones
frankly because it's a tough place